yesterday First Lady Melania Trump did
you hear about this she appeared at her
first White House event in a month yeah
yeah where's Milania put it they found
me she was in an umbrella stand yeah get
out of there let's go
speaking of Donald Trump it's been
reported that Donald Trump's family
fortune originated from a brothel
started by his grandfather yeah is that
shocking there was once a there was once
a Trump business that made money in a
brand new interview Vladimir Putin says
he regularly talks over the phone with
President Trump regularly yeah who says
it's not a big deal I like to check in
with all my employees
the head of Starbucks Howard Schultz did
you hear this he has announced that he's
leaving the company yeah Schultz said I
can't keep living a lie the coffee at
Dunkin Donuts is way better that was a
strong reaction yeah that was people
going yeah some good coffee in a TV
interview
Woody Allen says he has always been a
big supporter of hashtag me too and that
he should be the face of the movement
yeah I think it's really nice to see
Woody Allen is doing comedy again back
to the good stuff
a new report came out and it claims that
there are no I repeat no benefits to
having sex with a robot now keep in mind
this report is coming from the robots
I'm trying to work don't touch that but
use what use do I have for flowers
sentimental you think that's what
they're doing with the robots
you got a romance the robots first I
know now that's the whole point you
don't let's see it there okay a video
has surfaced from a Burger King of two
mice running around inside a bag of
hamburger buns yeah or as Arby's calls
that the special
you
you